let's speak now to Saudi Arabia's
ambassador to the UK as Royal Highness
Prince Khalid bin bandar al-saud who's
at the labor Party Conference in
Liverpool thank you very much for being
with us and uh first of all I wonder
tell us more about the role that Saudi
Arabia played in this release of British
prisoners and others held by Russian
proxy forces how did Saudi Arabia get
involved
uh well thank you for having me Mark
um so is Royal Highness the Crown Prince
from the very start of the conflict
offered to provide whatever help he
could to bring the conflict to an end in
March last year he spoke to both
presidents zielinski and Putin in and
offered you know any measures that Saudi
Arabia could provide
by April he had started hearing that
there was a complication in a prisoner
swap bill that was being negotiated and
the sticking point was these 10 foreign
Fighters he took it upon himself to get
involved quietly as we like to conduct
our diplomacy and used his offices to
you know
negotiate and discuss with with
President Putin on the release of the
the 10 and I'm very proud and happy to
say he managed to convince the president
and they're all back with our families
now safe and sound right so this was a
President Putin's request because a good
friend of his is also released and other
Russians was it a President Putin's
request
no not at all the discussions that the
wider discussions that were happening
with other countries and other leaders
around the world principally in Turkey
were happening concurrently his Royal
Highness got involved himself
he believed it was the right thing to do
it's a good humanitarian cause he'd had
discussions with various world leaders
who had prisoners in Russia and thought
he would see what he could do to help
okay now Crown Prince as you say got
involved
um
and the prisoners are clearly very
grateful do you think it helps to
rebuild relations with the West after
the khashoggi killing the murder of
which the Saudi government was
implicated in was that part of this
not not directly no um
I think the Crown Prince saw the
opportunity to do the right thing
nothing more nothing less and he saw
you know we conduct our diplomacy
um quite often in a quiet way we don't
always have to be seen to be doing the
right thing we just do the right thing
when we see there's an opportunity to do
so and I think this is a good example of
that it's also a good example of us
doing what we can for our friends around
the world
um our alliance with the UK goes back
100 years so there's nothing more than
that I I would I would say but it does
provide an example of where we can play
a huge role in a significant role to
help things along around the world right
I mean stability is is as important for
us as anyone else okay it also shows a
close relationship with Russia a
relationship that seems to have survived
the invasion of Ukraine does Saudi
Arabia condemn that invasion
I mean you would have seen our voting
record at the U.N we don't believe that
um issues between nations can be solved
by infringing upon territorial
sovereignty and with that applies to us
in our region as it does anywhere else
in the world
um
we would like to see the conflict
brought to an end it affects everyone in
the world not just through Energy prices
but you know the Grain and food stuff
imports from Ukraine and Russia into the
Middle East are incredibly significant
so food security is important
um but it's also important this is a
very good example of the fact that we
have the ability to talk to many people
I think shows and highlights the
importance of Saudi Arabia we can talk
to the East and the South the way that
that many others can't and I think
um that's not something to be to be
scoffed at and I think this shows uh how
important of a player is Saudi Arabia's
uh to the you know the world order well
I mean but much of the world has turned
its back on President Putin he's
considered a pariah Saudi Arabia has
invested increased investment in Russia
it's increased the oil you're buying
from Russia you're helping to prop up
oil prices with Russia should you not be
isolating uh this man who has
um you know invaded an independent
country in the way he has
um International prisoners are now free
had we
isolated Russia we wouldn't have been
able to achieve that that aim and so I
think that the families of those that
have been returned to them be very
grateful that we did manage to bridge a
gap there's always a place for someone
to bridge a gap and that's what we're
doing we have a tremendous relationship
with the West as we do with the East and
it's practical on many fronts
but it's important to keep that dialogue
going that's how we believe we engage
with the world is to keep the dialogue
going we engage with people we don't
like all the time
How concerned are you by what you're
seeing in Iran these protests by women
who are fed up with the way that they're
being treated when it comes to dress and
so forth uh does it worry you or will it
encourage you to bring more change to
Saudi Arabia
were there two elements to that question
I think we we are watching what's
happening in Iran with great concern
um Iran uh is obviously a major player
in our region and in further instability
Iran is not good for anyone I think that
they need to have a good look at the
policies that they have and what it's
doing to their people if you look at
Saudi Arabia it's part of the second
part of your question
not just the last five years the last 10
15 20 100 years you've seen a positive
development Trend in the way Saudi
Arabia is developed and I think it's a
it's an example to many of how you can
improve things and I think
not just Iran but many people can learn
from that uh that change in that
positive development and and I think
they need it there but ambassadors you
can see with the protests but Ambassador
women's rights in your country are still
heavily curtailed a male relative is
still required to give permission for a
woman to get married to to start certain
sorts of businesses there's still
restrictions on a women's dress code in
several areas of Saudi Arabia
the inlook one can pick a snapshot of
the development of a country and use
that as the defining character you know
period of time but if you look at the
where we've gone where we've come from
and the change that's happened in the
particularly the last five years is
dramatic 45 percent of Enterprises new
Enterprise in Saudi are run by women uh
37 of our labor force is now women and
that's gone up 300 in four years
um the majority of the guardianship
guardianship system has been uh
eliminated and so right you can't just
take a picture and say this is where you
are you have to look at where we're
going and where we've been yeah I don't
know I do I do yeah we're looking good
there has been change but many women's
rights activists are still
obviously in prison look we're running
out of time but I just want to end
finally with why the Crown Prince didn't
go to the Queen's funeral is this a
result of these still
difficult relations because of what
happened to khashoggi and
you know the Saudi government's role in
that
no not so we had you know the the the
funeral was obviously something that
happened unexpectedly and last minute
and we couldn't manage to figure out
some of the details involved in in the
uh the trip uh you know the movement of
someone
it was it can do a head of state is not
easy
and there's nothing more to it than that
and just there's certainly no problems
between travel and hopefully we'll have
a trip soon and just finally though do
you accept the damage that has been done
to the relationship with this country
and other Western countries by the
murder of khashoggi
happen in Istanbul sustained on the
relationship the
reputation of Saudi not just as a
government but as a country and its
people and I wish it had never happened
but we've we've done what we can to stop
it from happening again and I think like
I said it's positive developments in
Saudi and I think that's that's what we
need to focus on
all right Ambassador listen I appreciate
your time thanks for coming on the
program
thank you for having me